what's up fool podcast with Felipe spa
and back all the way back from sakas on
the Mexican tour Rodrigo Torres is back
yeah man what's happening everybody
what's up man you what's up man if you
um I heard you were running around like
Apocalypto over there bro all loaded and
[__] no only gotten loaded like two
nights dude but uh no it was cool dog
went from sakas to Mexico City everybody
wants to know bro what was what was a
weed situation like fool nothing dog I I
brought Edibles dog wow they wore out in
five days though but um yeah um I didn't
smoke any weed dude I smok cooka dog I
didn't even know you're supposed you're
not supposed to inhale that [__] dog
boring hell yeah for it made me feel hot
that was it dog I understand people do
that like hookah and vaping and blowing
out
smoke man they just hold it so they just
they don't inhale it no it's like a
cigar you just you Sim it in your mouth
all that's why I can never smoke
cigarettes bro yeah cigarettes you
inhale them right yeah cigarettes yeah
but cigars too you just put them in your
mouth it's like what the [__] dog it
didn't even give me Buzz dog let [__]
the talian be Smoky
dog that's crazy man so go to the
pyramids or what yeah that's ATI wakan
which is a civilization before the Aztec
it's 45 minutes outside of Mexico City
they have the Pyramid of the sun and the
Pyramid of the moon right there that's
funny man we have artifacts in Mexico
huh hell yeah in United States all they
have the Philadelphia
they hell yeah in America they got to
make monuments bro Olympus dick it's
like from 1787 on right or 1775 that's
it fool it lasted H that calendar hell
yeah dick is that the most accurate dude
it's [__] um thicker than that dude
so I would say it probably goes back
like [__] five feet dog but they that
one they found in Mexico City when they
were [__] shooting for um they're
digging for phone lines in like the 60s
cuz the Aztec Ruins are underneath
Mexico City they they never are going to
uncover them that one they found cuz
they [__] pushed through with the
bulldozer fool so Mexico City used to be
a river yeah it's a it's no it was like
um it's in like wetlands and [__] so um
but it's underneath Mexico City right
now so Mexico City every every year
sinks three centimeters fo so that
shit's like slowly sinking too because
of its what the way it's uh sitting on
the land the way yeah man well that's
why they have earthquakes I guess yeah
well they just had one [__] uh last
week f it wasn't that hard cor was like
5.7 though but in ' 85 they had that
hardcore one when a lot of people died
and [__] and uh all those older
buildings got [__] flattened and [__]
they got a lot of Mexican hipsters over
there yeah fol it's a with cash yeah F
Mexico City is a different world dog
like dude the vegan spots that had a
grip of vegan spots [__] but mean
hipsters fool Mexican hipsters Mexican
ones like not the fesa ones like the
ones that are kind of like the little
sweaty gross fools right there they're
all kind of fat dog with little tight
ass shirts and dumbass beards and
dumbass hats and pointy ass shoes
you want see any comedy clubs over there
I didn't PE peek around for that but um
I know they're starting to have it in
English over there in English in English
yeah man time to go over there that's
what I'm saying fool start start
reclaiming my jokes over there [__] yeah
dude put those [__] in a
headlock too dog [__] try to
snatch fool so man what you do over
there went you a wedding or what well uh
the first one uh was just that first uh
uh Saturday and my cousin um she
graduated from law school so they threw
a little party for and uh that was it
dude that was the main reason I went she
invited me back in August so I set the
little two weeks apart and um yeah man
just did that and [__] hung out fool
and how big is that foone bill though uh
dude I [__] when I went over I didn't
I didn't check with T-Mobile but there's
all [__] text are free and then
[__] uh phone calls are 20 20 cents a
minute but I didn't really call too much
dude I just text and need white people
over there a grip fool there's a there
was a handful in sakas and there's a
grip in Mexico City fool just a lot of
people from America or other places all
over dog [__] I ran into in sakas I
ran into some English fools some Finnish
fools [__] right there drinking and
[__] um and there's Chinese people and
[__] uh sakas and there's Kenyans
fool cuz they run I guess the altitude
and these [__] compete all over
Mexico for running championships fool
the Nigerians and [__] um in Mexico City
I seen some so everybody hot Melting Pot
hardcore fool everybody's there dude
French fools D Cubans dog over their
[__] uh they went dude totally dud
complaining dog everybody dude those
fools were comedy dog Cubans are so um
the older Cubans man they're all into
politics huh oh to the core dude they
are they knew what was going try to save
a dollar
house hell dude cuz all that [__]
happened with them when they got Jack
when filel Castro came in there so they
hipped to that [__] they know what's
going on dog that's why people here man
in America a lot of people are into
politics a lot of people are not but wa
till we get our ass kick bro oh then
that's remember after September 11th
yeah everybody was into politics [__]
dude now everybody's all happy again
hell yeah remember Bobby bites yeah that
was like we was like The Fat Cats by the
pole I was performing with American flag
on my back hell yeah to that without
jokeing the turbing dog yeah man what's
up fool any dates uh dates yeah um
Chicago no 19th and 20th Weed Street
Joe's Bar yes people Corpus chrisy Texas
July 21st to the 23rd I'll be at msit
Street comedy club J July 21st to 23rd
oh man West Palm Beach Florida August
4th through the 7th at The Improv Tucson
Arizona August 12th at TCC Music Hall
Pueblo California wait a minute they
know Pueblo California scratch that PUO
Colorado August
13th at Memorial Hall also
people just added a Fallout gig because
a Fallout gig means that somebody
cancelled so Felipe has to go over there
and pick up the
pieces last minute you know because you
know they figure phip got people that
show up so yes people I'm cover to
[__] New York City I'll be at the
[__] Carol comedy club on Broadway
baby on Broadway Felipe made it to
Broadway in New York City if you make it
there you'll make it anywhere it ain't
Levity Live in the [__] Boonies it's
New York City on Broadway bman get your
Baron whatever that [__] is airb airnb
anybody goes to New York City on
vacation we're going to have ticket
links we're going to have the hookups
for everybody we're all going to be in
New York City [__] yeah dog and and
we'll see what happens
man also man shout out to and a big
thank you for Dustin Ibara filling in my
little son all for the last two weeks
yeah yeah guys you know guys yeah man
yeah christella toldo my joke a shut up
fo what's up fool anyway so I'm not GNA
say you guys want to ask Dustin what
happened with that you guys ask him on
his social media ask him hey bro is that
true cristella stole your joke or is
using your joke or is doing your joke on
her next special I'm not here to say
pass out drama but I'm just letting out
the
facts hell yeah so what's up fool also
check out the yeah man podcast with
Rodrigo Torres this week he has Jared
Carter the party starter but that fool
don't start no parties he just starts a
merch table
the true story I don't know he mentioned
on his podcast but he probably got
scared we I mentioned it many times he's
the guy went to to that wh house in um
no he didn't mention it in um to Arizona
yeah the swinger spot yeah that fo was
there with [__] Richard Simmons
Shores bro and tube socks that fo wasn't
chees TW Cheetos eating Cheese Nips bro
watch you a threesome if you watching a
thre no bro a four some godam A lady
blowing a guy when another guy was
behind her and there was a guy behind
him jerking off watching it and me and
Darren Carter were eating Cheese Nips
bro and they were all in a Jacuzzi bro
God damn dude I swear they were not
wearing condoms raw raw hard God damn
Yeah man so if you guys want to hit up
Duran Carter on Instagram or Twitter and
ask him hey bro what happened at that um
Swingers Bar you and Filipe went to in
Arizona and let's see if he does a
little joke about it like I like my
Swingers Bars like I like I like my
women like I like my Swingers Bar eating
ches nibs and watching a
threesome Bow Wow
Wow check him out man because his he's a
party starter he's a rooster right now
his head's on
fire he also had my
homie Luis B
what's up D that say right yeah I always
say Jose he looks like a Jose dog he
does look like a Jose he look like a
Marcos
Mar that fool smells bro like a
forklift f [__] for real bro that
food smells like [__] like wood
gloves [__] petroleo petroleo now
that's the homie right there man that
fool came in like a soldier to pick me
up in s Bernardino dude this fo said he
went all the way to Camas on for your
ass
dog he said all the way to ID dog and he
said thank you dog and he gave me a CD
in the shirt dog I have no money dog I
still have it
do that fo said straight up let's go say
hi to my friend
first so I said all righty so we went to
a strip bar bro and he told everybody hi
hey look who I'm with e I'm with this
guy I'm shy
and you had Alfred robless if you
watching live I'm going to do it
lip that f b top lip looks like a
clitorus so who else also Angela Castle
we're lagging our next episode but we're
going to probably do it tonight hell
yeah talk about we're going to talk
about what happened to us bro because my
wife and I we took mushrooms oh how was
it f we talk about it all right list you
do yours no not yet fool I just took a
little cap and [__] kind of passed
out I felt a little weird F I was doing
great so I started watching something on
TV then I thought I started thinking
about it I said man I remember I wanted
a toy Monopoly and my brother wanted
quiz whiz and he got it oh D so I keep
focusing on that is it's funny how how
mushrooms work because how when you're
pissed off you want to focus I was
pissing you off right and I wanted to
focus on being pissed off about that and
whatever let whatever but the mushrooms
said n [__] n we're going to
focus on we're going to focus on Happy
[__] go back outside the stars with the
nature fo and that's when it comes you
start breathing out good it brings it
brought me Good Vibes yeah fool we're
all made of car dog I think people who
have depression hardcore depression
should eat
one cap at least that's it dude I fell
asleep with the [__] looking at my
[__] ceiling fan and I just fell
asleep with a smile and passed out I
thought I had two
rabbits
what's up with two socks i s I was in
Fourth of July bro at the Marino Del
Hotel was it awesome awesome Jamaica in
oh hell yeah yeah man and the door it
has to um to set the room service you
don't want to be there Jamaican me crazy
I'm
sleeping you guys take it dog yeah man
dude what dog oh my God I was tripping
just watching people fight during
traffic to get out of the beach really
fol mad traffic bro mad traffic people
were honking honking at each other
getting crazy these people are about to
start fighting and I yell up from the
balcony hey happy birthday America and
then it stop F they looked at me like
like you know it brought light to the
fight dude you're fighting in a parking
lot we're all going to leave for bull
what happen this bro this is what
happened that this will piss you off the
police is doing a good job blocking in
people from making a left and a right
but they're not doing a good job
stopping people from coming in back into
the beach so those people that were
coming in Back to the beach we're doing
a uour and blocking the [__]
that been waiting forever so it's all
[__] deadlock [__] yeah deadlock so
what would you do if a fool just came in
and just try to go in right away when
you've been waiting for an hour fool I
just put honestly fool I'll probably bow
yeah there's a cop right there and you
don't know everybody passing out bad
lies there a checkpoint a checkpoint but
there's no checkpoint [__] put that
[__] in park and [__] it dog that's it
what are you going to do fight and
flip-flops dude it was funny man there
was a a white lady with her pushing a
baby and she had a baby on her back on
her front pocket yelling on the phone
and I don't know what she was looking
for probably her husband yeah and then I
just said Larry are you still
surfing he's catching a wave my wife
died bro because I thought when I was
like tripping I we're going to talk
about in Castle but I tell you right now
um fool I remember dog growing up that
we had a washing machine but we had to
put two coders in
it your dad got one of those yeah and
then my wife asked what what would
happen to the coders and I said oh after
the wash was done the coders would come
out so it had that free thing when it
just came out but needed a quarter for
it to work yeah hell yeah I don't know
where the [__] he got that [__] that
[__] was stolen dog my uncle had some of
those dude that's he used to charge his
wife dog like what the [__] dog this
cheap ass [__] N Dog one time I
was trying to wash when nobody was there
I had no quars
dog I was was in a I was in a b trying
to crush up two nickel bro yeah you
smash we used to smash them with hammers
to play Street Fighter dog that's funny
every time my mom and dad were gone I
was trying to break into the machine to
trying to figure it out so I could go
back to the laundry man and steal their
quars you you need those skeleton keys
dog you need something dog hell yeah F
but you have fun out there man dude it
was [__] awesome dog it just like
[__] it just so fast every day I was
doing something and you know
[__] want to take you here and
there and uh dude [__] love
getting [__] up out there with alcohol
dog so you didn't hook up with no chicks
over there oh [__] no [__] you
got turned down in two countries no f i
i got me a little shine right now dude
I'm good right now you should have went
after at least try it bro pick up on a
canyon woman or something not even I the
canyon speak Spanish yeah fool a dude
[__] be speaking different
languages out there and [__] hey how do
those fools feel about what they say
about Mexicans in America fool those
fools don't like Trump dog they're man
what the [__] up with that guy is he
really going to win man we can't let him
win dog that F that fo's too full of
[__] fool fo that fool [__] up
yesterday dog what what did he do this
time oh dog but after um cuz you know um
a couple of countries got hit with um
terrorist hits during the um bombings
during Ramadan right and um there was a
big big ass bombing in um in um Baghdad
Iraq and 215 people died damn it was a
massive Isis took credit for it right
[__] up and then um he Donald Trump
praised Saddam Hussein are you [__] how
good he dealed with terrorists what the
[__] is wrong with that idiot dog I know
dog on one side you got um Hillary
Clinton praising President Obama on what
good a job of the president he did right
and um he could have not praised Obama
to do the good thing you know for his
party he could have said bad things
about obam how he maybe in his opinion
he's not doing a good job but to praise
a a a a dictator that we went after yeah
some for the [__] persecuted the
Kurds dog what the [__] is this problem
dog [__] got a billion dollars
zero brain cells crazy huh the [__]
idiot dog yeah man and then the other
week not so long ago like 4 days before
that he put up a a post with um greedy
Hillary Clinton with a a Sixpoint star a
Jewish
star and then after that when he got a
bunch of hate he took it off and then he
put it back with a circle but it was too
late bro so then so then um he changed a
circle but then people you know you
can't erase Twitter when you have a a
lot of followers [__] no he's cutting on
the Jews Now dog what the [__] is this
problem dog I don't know man it's when
you go off book it's like me when I'm
doing my [__] I'm killing it but they
try to improvise I start sucking bro for
real no I know you should follow your
program in life people if you used to
certain doing something a certain way
that works with you you know keep doing
it you know and then then you try to
change it up too fast you [__] up you're
right you got to start changing little
by little a little bit you can't just go
out and start talking [__] about
somebody you got to say it little by
little like Donald Trump should start
saying first of all start saying first
you know what I never really like
tacos I never really no honestly I never
like inchadas and then later on say you
know what I never really like going to
Mexico you know and then later I start
saying you know you going to build your
way yeah totally dude he [__] has no
intro sentence fo like me man dog like
you know who the devil is [__] that
[__] you got know who he is oh
man F L B has some funny ass stories
about charos bro he's yeah dog he tried
to get me to go party with him dog all
he wanted was tags dog I don't work for
free no more dog said he was staring him
down one time trying to punk him and
[__] that's how he is dog I I know Punk
I've been locked up dog I know how it is
dog so I told him what the [__] you
looking at dog I will [__] you up
dog what that food locked up for bro um
dude spilling oil no spilling oil in a
[__] the drain fool this this is what
happened dog he was going to go to work
and his boss used to pick him up before
I had a car dog so my boss was beeping
dog and then the neighbor across the
street said okay my mom's out
I and the guy's all shut the [__] up
[__] so I took it in dog I had a choice
to make dog let that fool talk [__]
about my mom that was his boss no no not
the guy from across the street cuz the
boss was beeping right or tell the boss
to go on without me and go handle this
[__] dog so I had to go handle
it dog I walk across the street he goes
into his house dog I kick in the door
dog I [__] him up so bad dog he
couldn't call the cops the neighbor C
the
cop I don't know what they got him for
bro they got that for breaking an injy
yes they got him for burglary dog the
burglary and of salt and battery for it
and Battery a aggravated battery four
counts dog he only got two dog I think
he ended up getting one and what you
know what the that sticks with you
though yeah but you know what the Silver
Lining is fool F like two years later
they hear a scream ah ah from across the
street it was him dog I had to go save
him dog he went to his attic dog and the
ladder fell dog so he's sitting there
with his leg screaming dog and I put the
ladder up dog like a good citizen and I
helped him down dog he got arrested two
days later dog he was a coke dealer
dog I'm like what's up you going to try
to get that [__] expunged after record
I'mma try dog you know anybody dog this
was a soldier F was an iron worker [__]
got a good coke dealer man cuz if I
[__] beat him up dog they should have
[__] robbed them
me yeah fool l v that's that's been my
week bro I hav't what was my last
show
was it Birmingham or or Orlando July
22nd stay strong Orlando June 22nd oh
you were there for your birthday weekend
I there for my birthday bro oh that's
when that whole Orlando shooting went
down yeah man wow I haven't done a set
in a while but doing the podcast feels
like a said bro it is fool like it's
weird dude you [__] you feel that
you've gotten better cuz I mean you
always been do good at doing stand up
but this is a whole another medium dude
it feels like you can think like on your
like feet and flow better huh yeah man
you got got a lot of things to say too
man yeah fool like I was afraid open I
went body boarding dog I wasn't oh dude
I [__] look at my forehead bro my
forehead look a leather belt I thought
you hit something F oh no man I almost
got caught in a a dog Rip Tide Rip Tide
see man I some cholo got caught in a
Riptide when I was there you just stayed
calm CH think that they could Mad Dog
the wave bro [__] no you can't tell the
wave what's up wave where you from wave
what's up [__] pin allaha hola hola I
[__] stab you wave so these [__]
dudes go in there with their C shorts
bro swimming and [__] swimming out hard
and then they're going past next to [__]
let's go next to the Surfers they [__]
these put fool if you're not a good
swimmer you can't get to the Surfers
[__] no so these fools are right there
halfway in between the Surfers and the
other people trying to swim back and
they can't they're stuck in the
Whirlwind the whir pool of water the Rip
Curl and they're getting pulled back for
this [__] is lifeguard solid kept waving
them back and those F kept waving and it
look like they were telling him nah
we're cool but n bro I've been in a
situation you just scared so they were
stuck so that fool had to go over there
bro he was [__] he swam he just threw
that orange thing at them bro he didn't
want to swim he didn't want to swim in
there cuz they both get stuck so he
threw the orange thing at him and he
pulled that fool and the other fool got
pulled too fool I saw that [__] cholo
kissing that fool's hand dog
[__] respect dog you saved my life
holes you saved my life holes [__] it he
got a tattoo with a red cross bro dude
you can't [__] with it dog that fool was
autopress dog he was
like that's what happens F cuz it keeps
pulling you out you keep getting tired
fol you can't swim at it you got to
[__] just put l if you ever get
caught in a Rip Curl in the ocean people
this is what you do you stop swimming
and you [__] make yourself float and
and then let the [__] water push you
out into the ocean make a right and a
left and then swim away from that [__]
and take the next big ass wave back into
the ocean sand and swim and paddle or
pedal like a doggy padal uh parallel to
the beach and then catch the waves going
back in yes you got to parallel swim out
to the beach okay and then let the wave
bring you back because when you're stuck
there you can't come back man and you
you can't freak out you got to stay calm
fol and if you're not a [__] good
swimmer if you're a fat ass stretch out
before you go in that water cuz you have
a cramp and later on bro that's it
bro hell
yeah yeah there's a lot of crazy ass
Surfers out there bro hell yeah dude
[__] who's been dude I want to do
that [__] paddle board [__] but um I
might go paddle boarding this week bro
hell yeah fool that be [__] sweet
yeah man that's awesome though the beach
feels good H yeah so went to I went body
boarding four times bro hell yeah you
have fun hell yeah fun dog and then um I
went to Marina del re on Saturday and
the waves were like cool bro they were
pretty big in a shallow end so I really
have to swim at them I would just see
the wave coming and I just dive in bro
and I was doing good [__] yeah dude cuz
I went to the beach at night when I got
back when s sanan capestrano that [__]
was cool we didn't go in the water
though lot of rocks there huh uh yeah
dude but we sh on the Little Sandy par
dude no took down some kid bro for what
fool well I was coming in from the way
real hard and I was out of control and
and and I went and I put my body board
to the right to avoid hitting him but my
big fat ass calf still got him down bro
you [__] whipped him whipped them bro
oh dude see that's another Force too dog
the waves are [__] dude they're
monstrous and mad dude it's crazy also
man before you go into the water if you
never swam and you're not a good swimmer
and you never got into the ocean and you
have your kids even before your kids go
in there walk up to the Lifeguard and
ask the Lifeguard how safe is the ocean
right now where are the rip tides you
know where are is it safe for my kids I
asked that lifeguard hey man where is it
safe to go in the water he straight up
said no it isn't there you go he goes if
you goes so stay in the shallow wind you
know if you're not a good swimmer don't
go to the follow these body boarders I
saw this [__] this 60-year-old man who
showed up with a body Su and a bodyboard
and he was trying to go bodyboarding in
the Deep area fool that food come came
out of that water in 15 minutes talking
about man not even I could even make it
out there dude especially you can't go
out there [__] with training wheels
you have your bodysuit on and [__] hell
no I a fat seal bro I don't want to get
eaten by a great white and you have you
never noticed a helicopters where they
comb like the the waves they're looking
for sharks fool they better dog they
better fool then not there a lot of a
lot of um you know a lot of people like
Mexican people Salvadoran Nikos you know
Latino people selling fruit all over the
hustling dog $5 for a little cup of
mango I had to talk to the lady how many
do you sell a day she go some a good I S
three that's five three of them bro
that's it three crates oh three oh
godamn okay hell there like 20 and 10 $5
each that's 150 bucks [__] yeah dog
that's what I'm saying I seen the little
[__] Snapchat you were doing this
lady right here but all like undercover
style F did you say you guys went to the
beach was at Venice a couple years back
and the lady [__] she was like all
like had a blanket over and everything
cuz they popped her the day before you
guys went and [__] hell yeah F sometime
the lady man when she trying to hide she
be hi like like there be blankets
already laid up she just sits next to it
bro post a little Neo next to it and you
know what's funny dude there's a hustler
lady at K in Riverside fool they bust
the cops busted her right so you know
how she did it now dog fool she does it
in a baby stroller now like she covers
it up like she has a baby sell at TH my
dog they haven't busted her F I saw a
guy in a wheelchair on the on where with
a big ass um he rented one of those um
one of those U wheelchairs for the
beach has big old TIR monster tires that
fool was rolling bro checking out chicks
too with his
camera I didn't see the Pervert though
what the [__] up with that fool I
didn't see him bro
but I bet they were looking for him dude
look at that for knuckle sandwich dog
something bro call up homie from Ireland
bro Li in for a ass be I bet you bro you
would ask anybody or Carl bro Glen Glenn
Carlin I bet you would ask any of our
listener bro we're going to fly you out
but all you got to do bro is slap the
devil in the
face we'll fly you out all expenses paid
we're going to flood the market dog just
do a Dr drive by
slapping F that drive by dick
slapping okay man if they're a Long Dong
Silver what's up fool we got our first
caller in the house
yeah what's up F what's up fool man
where you calling
from I'm calling from Winslow Arizona
man goddamn Winslow Arizona bro shout
out to Winslow Arizona hell yeah what's
up Jojo left his home and Winslow Arizon
for some California Grand that's right
random real big fans man we saw you in
10p two years ago and uh we follow your
podcast and and uh everything you do man
we're real big fans out here in
Arizona we love your podcast man thank
you bro we love you too what's your name
my name is Nick arano Nick arano what's
up Nick hell yeah hell yeah bro I'm
coming to tucon Arizona bro
oh yeah when you guys going to Tucson
we're gonna be in Tucson Arizona August
12th at the
TCC Music Hall oh man I have to try to
make it out there man but uh yeah every
time you come to 10p man we try to check
you guys out thank you bro thank you for
calling in bro appreciate that much love
hey no yeah thanks man can I get a shout
out my boys Allstar team playing today
12y old wi allars tell them what's up
fool what's up big d i I will man I
appreciate it man you guys keep doing
your thing man thank you Nick keep
shining dog yes
sir hello what's up
fool what's up
fool hey what's up man what's up man
where you calling from I'm calling from
Florida Florida in the house H yeah dog
the pan handle what's happening I'm
coming to West Palm Beach bro I'm on the
other side bro I'm on Tampa Side Tampa
oh what's up from Tampa eore City in the
house yeah bro yeah man I I seen you
guys show like twice I saw you last time
you came with uh Keith Manning yeah
what's up man what's up man what's your
name uh Rick what up Rick what's up do I
had a question for you yes yeah man hey
bro are you working on a uh comedy album
yes I'm working on one hour special a
new one I'm recording it August 28
August 27 in San Jose it'll be out and
I'm also after I record it it'll be out
on Netflix we're trying to SLE it but
also I'm going to make a special a
limited uh vinyl album of that special
I'm going to make a 100 copies and then
I'm going sign them all and it's going
to be a regular vinyl album like the old
school ones with art and pictures inside
and a lot of nice stuff that's cool cuz
look you might I'm crazy but man like
while back few months ago I had a dream
you want to gr me man for the
album what God damn the Suiter over here
dog hell yeah you're a wizard so so keep
that up man if you the in the gramy just
give me a shout out I will give you a
shout out bro if I would have grab me
hell yeah
Ricky hell yeah thank you bro yeah man
just you know you know I'm probably
[__] around but for real man you know
some [__] like that happens oh [__] you
never know you never know dog
you never know thanks for calling what's
up I was listening to your podcast this
morning man pretty good [__] from over
there from is all this [__] you're
schooling everybody on man oh yeah man
[__] yeah dude thank you very much for
listening big dog yeah man and uh who
else can I mention uh yeah what other
dream did you have what you coming back
next year over yes I coming back next
year to Tampa but I'll be in West Palm
Beach August 4th through the 7th all
right see I can make I tried to make it
to your Orlando on but uh yeah you know
I ain't trying to get caught up a away
with them folks hell no f h yeah man you
have another gay club to go
to Crazy Adam muray man I little big
than last time man he was a what he look
bigger than last time dog I know right
that like [__] Grizzly
Adam yeah like damn this got big those
cras dog I know for I thought I thought
he was like [__] A Tiny Tim
yeah but that's cool though another
thing I don't I don't get that reference
you guys do with Keith Manning get off
the field oh man because he's a big um
Patriots he's a big Patriots fan New
England Patriots that fo puts on a a New
England Patriots hat underwear socks
shoes shorts and every time they get a
good play he goes get off the field yeah
and that one day they won and he he just
told the other team after they scored
touches out get off the field get off
the field that's always always say even
had a gab congratulations to man hit a
baby with big
balls that's cool that's good know
thanks bro but uh yeah I just want to
give you guys a CL support podcast so
than keep on what you're doing hell yeah
thank you bro peace out dog three
minutes bro he had his own [__] he was a
guest he had a segment dog what's up
fool what's up F what's up m
Mond you sound like a friend Mond what's
going on let's go get
something yeah man yeah man what's
happening dog who's this is Eric man
Eric for real oh what up f for
real showed up to the ice what what's up
F what's up guys how's it going man good
bro love shows I love both of you guys
Rodrigo you guys are the [__] man thank
you bro we love you too bro you're the
[__] yeah man for real hell yeah man big
UPS on you Rodrigo too on your podcast
you know all it's all looking good bro
everything man gracias dog [__]
yeah's what's up guys how you how's it
going good bro how was your fourth of
July it was good bro you know I kicked
with the family just you know how
Mexicans do it a lot of food a lot of
beer you know it was a good time man it
was it was cool work on on Tuesday was
kind of a drag but you know it was cool
it was worth it I know man everybody
ched up with hangovers burn faces Los
fing I work for my job you know I'm a
beer salesman so [__] dude all my all my
accounts were all cleaned out man so
it's a good thing and a bad thing you
know but you know I'm blessed so I got a
job so you're
D yeah man you out right here I got a
big old beard belly hell yeah it's not a
beard belly bro it's a it's so rof for
your
penis a big ass room
dude for the
awning good hell yeah man what about you
guys how was your forth it was good bro
I was in Venice Beach Marino Del R
chilling having a good time shrooming
you know how we do
it I wouldn't know but you know sounds
like fun man still it's fun bro hell
yeah dog it's like you escape Without
Really
escaping right right right that's cool
man thanks for calling dog absolutely
man hey guys big up to you guys and I
love you guys all right man right back
at you dog all right guys see you B late
late what's up
hello hello hello up what's up who is
this oh what's up F [__] do what's
up what's up this is the tiny from San
Diego what up tiny what up tiny what's
up Tre boys chill
dude I've been thinking for like two
hours what I was going to say ass and I
couldn't think a [__] cuz I didn't want
to be like another annoying fan ask the
same question there you go yes
bro damn man this is like oh my God
[__] love you guys we love you too
the truck driver man oh yeah hell yeah
dude I could hear the truck give a
little truck honk hell yeah man Nebraska
man you ever going to Omaha before funny
going out there oh man I'm trying to
make it out there but give give him a
tell give him a give me a
recommendation I got your pad get on it
hey are you in a truck right now yeah
I'm on the truck right now I'm actually
heading to Kanas City give me a little
horn a little honk I got you
back one more do one more
bro what one more I got your back
bro oh C me like I'm like I got
butterflies in my stach right now now I
feel like I like talk to my crush for
the first time hey bro have you and I
met
before no uh no CU I met a truck driver
because every time you went to San Diego
I was on the road oh okay n man but uh
yeah I'm actually yeah I'm from s die
but my job's right here so it's like the
only time I'll be able to see went to
the funny bar here but like you said
can't go out there but man I'll get your
back and try to get a good word in even
though I don't know nobody thank you bro
just um just say hey man you guys heard
Felipe bring him
here right oh hey uh Rodrigo man you
[__] podcast I love that [__] Bro oh
[__] yeah thank you so much dog for
listening dog H yeah man keep it going
and shout out to uh J Bar man that a
funny ass guess H yeah man well tell him
bro what's
Happ this is crazy I
feeling hell yeah
I'm glad you made
it um I probably know wife about this
like you know I'm Mexican so you know
I'm a big ass boy but like I'm trying to
W but I need a big ass shirt bro how big
are you four
3x hey bro I'm a 5x right now man God
damn damn bro are you really are you
really driving that truck or you
fuckingo got him on the bed I'm pulling
him the man
[__] we'll try to make you one then fol
[__] it we'll get you I'll the extra C
I'm TR with we'll get you up bro I think
we could get you um a 4X you could buy a
4X hoodie right we got we got we got
what food podcast 4X hoodies right now
on sale on the web page felipesworld
docomo you can represent we're in the
what so podcast hoodie and a hat out
here in the hell yeah I bet dude oh my
God this is [__] wild [__] tiny
[__] Tiny Tim [__]
tiny oh [__] I S tell like since this
morning since I saw the picture on
Instagram I was like I need to ask for
something it's like thinking nothing
hell yeah bro hey bro you're a truck
driver what's your favorite snack when
you're
driving oh my god dude to be honest the
thing I eat the most is [__] I don't
even know if you consider a snack but uh
D pickles it's brand sunflower them
[__] are
fire D pickle sunflower seeds wow yeah
but they got to be the spit band you
know what I'm saying they got to damn
sounds good I used to drive and
sunflower seeds too bro yeah I remember
M saying that [__] keeps you up yeah
yeah keep keep your M when I'm driving
the you know poy watch the road bro give
me one more horn on the way out
a damn I'm this too all right I got you
back all right BR thank you tiny right
keep man look out for that
4X for
sure that was
five what's up hello is it me you're
looking
for yes it is how's it going guys what's
up fool who is this and where you're
calling from
this is Wolf Brown I calling from the
dog are you on moris cold bro what's
happen [__] got the Navajo talk going
we could barely hear you bro wind
talker smoke signals bro what's up fool
what's up with your friend using my joke
bro and changing it to
cousin yeah right that's was like I
don't even I I barely had that full I'm
like what the hell is this crap you drop
that fool hey bro you driving we could
barely hear you you should lower your
radio or something your radio oh
no yeah I don't have a radio no I'm call
from work I'm hiding out in my office I
close my door sh I'm like oh man I can't
miss this [__] are you calling from work
or you drowning dog damn bro you're
being choked try to call us back on
another connection on the real cuz it's
sounds too cut
up
okay all right bro call us back yeah man
yeah man yeah we're going to delete that
one hello
hello hey what's up man what's up fool
what's your name where you calling from
my name's I'm calling from Modesto
Modesto what's up [__] crazy because
I'm looking at the live stream and I was
like wait they're not talking to me
talking to you D we're talking to you
bro Ado from Modesto California the
209 yeah man I was I'm I'm glad to I'm
glad I'm on the line man and I was I
just want to thank you guys uh last time
you were doing the live stream I was you
guys were talking about voting and I was
like oh [__] I was actually I wanted to
call but I was actually running a
campaign in San Jose for voting so that
was crazy oh wow man so you trying to
get everybody to vote
register yeah no we were um yeah we were
out there um knocking on doors for uh to
elect the first like U Vietnamese lady
to um State Assembly nice hell yeah dude
that's awes what's her
name uh her name is um Madison WI
Madison win state assembly for Modesto
everybody look her up check out her
credentials you like her vote for her
did she
win yeah she did uh she she's going out
to the runoff in November so oh [__]
yeah dude [__] yeah combing those
precincts Yeah man so it was cool that
you guys were talking about that and I
like that you guys are are informing
folks out to get to get out to love man
and I mean I love your comedy so it it
makes it even greater that you guys are
doing that hell yeah hell yeah thank you
bro a pat on your back too dog for your
participation thanks man thanks but I'm
like go ahead like when I was when I was
out there knocking on doors I would like
I would have you guys on I would have
you on podcast I mean on you know on my
on my phone like while I was driving to
different areas but hell yeah you guys
you guys were a part of the the
preaching walking awesome tell those fol
to subscribe too
dog yeah bro tell tell to vote and
subscribe to the podcast yeah man yeah
man in the digital age you know
yeah yeah so you guys only come down to
you guys come down to mer man you never
come up to Modesto I know man we haven't
been to Modesto bro since the the
Raiders got disqual got um eliminated
from the playoffs by the Patriots and
the the the TU rule that was 2002 2002
God damn We performed at the State
Theater bro the State Theater it was it
was um the show was Rodrigo Torres Joey
cooko Diaz and me yeah man back in the
days huh that was that one day I was
talking for five hours you guys can
leave bro no keep on
talking 11 back then man thank you man
for calling bro I was
12 hell yeah hit us up dog all right man
thank you bro for listening man [__]
yeah spreading the word dog yeah man 20
two bro a long time ago now [__] yeah
dude was he all talking in the hotel
room dog for days hello
hello yeah man
yeah yeah dog Louis Bland dude that was
[__] days ago 5x bro oh [__] tiny
dog tiny 5x or 4X 5x oh wow we can
squeeze into a 4X come on dog what's up
fool hello where you from where you
calling from what's your name who's your
Daddy hey your dad Big T from Reno for
from we here oh what's up Ted
Martinez hey what's going on buddy my
Facebook Budd what's
up I enjoy you guys show man and I'm
almost a borderline stalker because I
freaking watch so much even the in
podcast I like it welcome back lgo guys
pretty funny too yeah man what's
happening dog thank you bro this is Ted
Martinez bro he went to the show and um
in Reno where that F passed out yeah the
tahoo they were with that whole party
yeah there with that guy um weaken a
Beres yeah was my my niece's husband he
got he got all p and was all trying to
hit on the big girl over there too the
whole night uh one of the ladies that
worked there that was
on what happened Reno St in Reno what
happened to Reno stays in
Laughlin
you because
been here for a little
while so what's up man did you get did
you get that camper or
what what's that did you buy a camper or
what yeah you saw my Facebook yeah man
got it's pretty good it's freaking the
old school style it's a older uh uh
freaking fifth wheel but it's like brand
new on the inside man it's like brand
new it's only like 22 foot so I just got
this go out and uh go out and drink
party on the campg out there go capping
the rest of Summer whatever Fu always
talking about out brother was in that
movie what's his
name um his name is George uh but he was
Guy the F that stood Jerry the guy that
stood up and said hey [__] the
world oh c the fo that had tattoo on his
lip yeah the tattoo actually that's your
cousin he was really locked up then huh
yeah it's my brother he's married to my
wife he's my brother my wife's brother
and he he he follow us at Torino too and
he passed away about five years ago from
from CER but he's a good dude man he was
crazy in that movie bro damn dude all
right all right man you guys don't take
too much your time it's good to talk
man hell yeah that's what's up dog
Rodrigo I like Rodrigo I like your
podcast too keep going man you're doing
good graas graas so now we have another
character from blood and blood out is
that crazy F the world [__] um small
world I can't wait to we get popey on
the show bro oh F hey dude I think frer
can hook that one up hook it up bro we
got frer too oh hit him up dude when I
get home I'll be tight huh papey oh dude
what's up
fool who's this where you calling
from citric citric what's
up what's up dog to your face
clothing TV
Land All Over The World clothing in the
building hell yeah hell yeah do what up
F he's right there Soul right now bro
yeah no she's like she's at work right
now she told me goes hey they're having
a live a live a live uh a live calling
so all right I'mma call in say what's up
to the homies what's up F what's up fool
how you been man you know we had juice
over here last time too yeah man I heard
I heard man [__] juice man you know
that's the homie right there always
putting it down [__] yeah [__] yeah yeah
I saw I saw him doing the the launch pad
right yeah the launch pad yeah man shout
out to the cats man they're doing it man
how you been man how was your fourth of
July did you do it big rasa style or or
small or what you know in between you a
little bit you know a little bit of you
know hamburgers and hot dogs and bacon
wraps you know and then uh have U I was
chilling right there with the with the
whole fan my grandson my Sol was there
you know and all my homies from the crew
you know we just blowing up the blocks
so it was good man blowing up the block
[__] yeah dog is there a lot of illegal
fireworks yes yes I was like [__] B
daddy that's we yeah man it l l like
yeah it l like the streets of Baghdad
man it was
war only day you don't know if their
gunshot
do well you know there was a couple
gunshots in between but you know I ain't
Point any seniors anywhere though you
know I know man when you're from the
hood that's what you play on that's the
game you play on Fourth of July
fireworks or bullets you name that sound
shotgun dog or a [__] 38 shotgun more
like douch
douch it's funny man people from the
hood that grew up in the hood can make
the best gunshot
noises it's my Hobie shot dog yeah man
how was it bro n bro they [__] shot
that [__] Douce
deuce or n [__] they shut that
[__]
P oh man they shut the [__] with
a
ster you didn't have a chance people
from the hood when they talk about a
shooting they always dramatize the
bullets the The Gunshot noises N Dog
they were
chasing mean voiceovers dog they stabed
that the uzi
sounds
n man shot that with a shotgun bro
douche to the back dog
no with the extra round clip so what's
up bro how's the show doing how's the
George Lopez show doing on TV Land uh
well the season's over already man I
mean everything went good you know so
right now you could basically uh catch
it on demand now you know anybody got on
Dem man you'll be able to see all all 12
episodes you know a lot of people were
telling me like man it's too short you
know but you know we got season two
coming all congratulations bro hell yeah
season two
baby you know so we're looking forward
to that man it's going to be it's going
to be pretty exciting man any inside
scoop what you guys are going to be
doing or
what well I mean we can't we know speak
too much on it because we're still
waiting for the writers you know to get
you know get situated but I tell you we
got P that story IDE floating around you
got to pitch that story bro you got
catch me doing George Lopez joke and you
put me in the truck
dog you got make me do you got got to
get me make me do and My Punishment bro
is cutting his grass like Richard V used
to cut Jeff Garcia's
grass he rodo
babysits now for real man I'm bring I'm
bring it up to him man baby see your
grandson dog hell yeah bro yeah man [__]
yeah dog yeah so you know what how was
you guys Fourth of July it was good man
I was in a Marina Marina del re and it
was funny they have a a firework show
that was pretty far away but in the area
there was a lot of cops right but there
was people actually with illegal
fireworks that that fo showed up bro he
was [__] shooting him in the sky man
and everybody was capping [__] yeah dog
you know that every time he shot that
with
$100 oh
yeah traffic was crazy once again
[__] mortars
though man it's always it's always good
out there though man I heard they got
some good fire they do man I remember
man when I was a little kid man I wanted
fireworks and my dad took out his
brow and he started snapping the bout to
make her like a cracker
noise look at black cats [__] when I was
little bro the only fireworks I had was
I had a little rocket a little rocket
and you put a little a little like a a
little red tap and you throw it in the
air and then when it lands
P you never had that little rocket nah
yeah I remember those yeah you put it
was a little cap right yeah remember
those you get them at the little liquor
store hell yeah dog [__] C over there
bro guns are so bad right now they don't
even sell cap guns no more I know huh
remember they should sell cap guns big
[__] C guns real ones metal
ones H yeah came they used to come with
a little round a little a little red
round fo I had two dog and I had one on
my ankle dog I was ready to go I used to
take that [__] to school yeah dog I used
to take my cap gun to school and I see
mother I'll be walking down I i' be
walking down to my seat and I see a
[__] on my seat and I put in his
head go why you [__] fake
r f dude you can't
they're whack now they're plastic the
[__] the school cop will kill you dog
hell
yeah
resour no those sh were [__] you
don't need a gun to get shot by the cop
no more bro you get sh you could get you
could get kill selling [__] CDs hell
yeah just tell him don't shoot me like
that like that brother who got shot in
in um bath Rouge Louisiana dog slanging
the [__] sling CDs you know what it
is man honestly we should if if it's a
an illegal
murder like the like the cop did like
the cop shot that guy I think we should
prosecute the person who made the
[__] phone call because that person
who called said he saw a gun where the
[__] is this [__] that's like
same way [__] inciting a [__] rer
do I think if a person call makes a
phone a call for anybody and says that
that person has a gun and that person
dies without a gun not only should the
cops she be prosecuted the person who
made the phone call should be prosecuted
more because he made a false call [__]
yeah well [__] double prosecute
different
that yeah dude that's some real [__]
that always happens you could really do
that now like if my wife were to be
pissed off oh my husband just left he's
walking with a gun and he's pissed off
and then I get shot you don't have have
no gun yeah dog it happens a lot bro no
dude [__] some legislator better
[__] hop on that [__] [__] dog
yeah man making false reports should be
prosecuted man you know stop blaming gun
owners you know oh yeah there's people
out there who have guns with locks oh
yeah fol but there are people out there
who don't have gun with
locks and then the little kid grabs if
you don't know how to raise a baby you
shouldn't be raising no gun [__] no all
right that's enough bro good off the
ra but I should make a LW just like just
like you know you know what bro finally
saying they're finally doing what um
Chris Rock said in 2002 man we should
just start charge it for bullets a
bullet control yeah a bullet control
Char every bullet should be $5,000 dude
you know they [__] keep an eye on the
bullets when you go to war and [__] why
don't they do that [__] here on the
street you're right Rodrigo for vice
president of K
Mar the sporting good
section
Department you see fat people shooting
people bro because their fingers don't
fit the trigger [__] shooting a
girl with a string with this pink
pink [__] fat people be shooting
people with their [__] Pinky J Dog
well thanks for calling Bro [__] Yeah
dog nice to hear from you thanks for
being another guest yeah dog it's always
good it's always good you know talking
to your homies and [__] man you guys are
always on point man so you know you guys
keep doing your [__] man we'll see you
on after season two dog we'll see you
October 15 bro at at um humph by the bay
in San Diego yeah man all right October
21st going man October 21st hell yeah
fool so it's October 21st yeah man all
right yeah you know yeah told me we're
talking about for sure that we want to
go out there and check out you know
we're gonna do it bro we're going to go
to Porto noo eat lobster just kidding I
don't eat lobster I'll smell it
dog no [__] man we might as well just
make that hop over man might as well bro
we drop Rodrigo at um
andas can't go that
spot oh come back this F
all right man well you guys stay up man
I'll talk to you guys soon hell yeah bro
[__] yeah [__] yeah
peace what's up fool how are you who's
calling where you from hey what's up man
this is Felipe car calling from
northeast side of Los Angeles man what's
up phip
caral I give this for shout out on
Facebook earlier you're too my toaso bro
from the north side bro
up
dog fipe just quick question man yes
bro that one day I se is coming out of
green wolf Collective
man what were you scoring man what kind
of Y were you getting if I can know man
oh bro it was that edible tell them
about the edible oh dude the the vegan
Edibles dude they [__] um dude they
have six doses but I cut them up into
four and dude they dude they last asked
me for four good [__] days dog and
they're the best ones yeah we were
traveling that day so we went in there
and I and I got like three of those
cupcakes they're they're they're um they
cost
$20 but he said he cuts them up in four
pieces I cut them up in six they're good
do they're the best ones I've ever had
yeah man and they and if you're if
you're like you're at a place where you
can't really like smoke or or you're
trying to stop smoking or trying to
smoke less these brownies are the best I
mean top Notch the best and they take
care of you also bro I hope I also also
like Moxy you know Moxy Gorilla Glue
yeah yeah I mess with that yeah I mess
with that bro but also bro if you would
to get them good stuff like some good
good good stuff you got to go to
downtown medicinal on Third and wall and
there's some stuff there called Louis
the 13th and um if you follow Louis the
13th and you follow him on Instagram
that guy he's his name is on that weed
and every Friday he hides an ather and
$60 in the city bro it's like a
weed scavenger hunt
yeah
dang that out man it sucks it sucks you
on your way out man because I wanted you
to sign my weed jard bro I would have
bro I will next time next time for sure
man when's your next show out here in La
bro actually the closest show to La it
will be August 10th at comedy magic club
in Hermosa Beach eat man man I'm gon try
to be there big dog than was pleasure
talking to you man my line bugging the
[__] out of me dog so all right bro
let's threeway right now on the phone
let's see what she
says hey I'm [__] down dog
dog all right man you have a good one
man care [__] yeah I don't know if we
related to The carbajal Boxers maybe
Michael carbajal and them yeah Rafael
carbajal hello hello what's up fool L
your Instagram I just heard myself on
the
radio what's up fool where you from who
is this what's up fol this big frog from
San Diego all right bye
what's up F got you hey bro honestly I
don't want to break the law right now
but by any chance do you have the new
season of that show on far on F on I
think it's called AMC that show
turn yeah no I can get it I love that
show bro oh hell yeah bro it's about the
George Washington days and how they use
spies tell me they use a lot of slaves
as spies [__] yeah a lot of a lot a lot
of the the house slaves that were inside
the house that they they knew how to
read English how to write and when they
separated her baby the baby went to
another house so she would like but she
was a very nice slave that the other
family was nice to her and they were
send NOS to each other right or presents
she was I'm sending my son a present but
inside bro she was telling them where
all the sh England ships were at and how
many troops were coming in [__] yeah do
that's [__] [__] domestic espan
yeah bro and and dog that lady's giving
away Secrets dog it's funny man how how
that's spying it's yeah W [__] around
either like if they thought you were
[__] spying some [__] then hang your
ass right now cuz we were doing that
against the king dog you know that's
[__] we were Rebels fooling G our
freedom these
firecrackers yeah they're yeah man
honestly the people don't talk about it
but the the when we want when America
wanted Independence they were considered
terrorists yeah we're [__]
revolutionaries dude we're [__] the
teabagging [__] hell yeah
fool just [__] little tax on your
[__] hey man but those [__] English
troops are walking into people's houses
and just laying up though oh yeah dog
imagine taking their food we got five
English troops you going to feed us you
going to we're going to use your beds
you got to [__] sleep outside and
their daughters yeah and their daughters
yeah dud scam us that [__] like that
fool but it's funny man how War changed
man because they used to fight like with
with with rules before like they would
tell you we're going to be there at five
with 200 troops and go [__] we have and
they'll [__] start druming little
drum roll they line up they line up but
you know what but if you have more
troops you can just Corner them with
lineing up yeah yeah on the other sides
dude and come in on them it was until
finally bro
um they the the the Indians told him a
man this is no way to [__] fight a
war hell yeah dog when we stepped into
[__] Vietnam they got us with that
gorilla Warfare [__] that I like your
bullet
noises I got him earlier what the [__] F
how you been dog you still selling Levis
or
what no Levis right now they got the
DVDs on Deck damn dog you watch that
show
turn hey so I was all sad that the
Felipe show got cancelled bro I wanted
to go to humph I never been there got
moved over dude no canceled it got moved
August I'm sorry October 21st Humphrey's
by the bay bro bees there bro bring your
boat I only been there one time I was
seen Santana there but I was so wasted I
don't really remember anything about it
Black Magic Woman over here oh man
that's one of the best places to watch a
comedy show or a music or event because
you can watch it from your room [__]
yeah dude it's [__] sweet hell yeah
that's what's up so what's up bro you
still married or what yeah man I took
out my girl she's a she's a number one
fan hell yeah man you guys still have
you guys having a baby soon or what no
no baby no baby no kids huh [__] that
huh I see I see all the homies that have
babies they can't do [__] no more man so
no Tad PS huh hell yeah man you
your no not for me well thanks for
calling dog oh yeah nice hearing from
right thanks for being the first guy to
like my post yeah man all right right
keep shining fool all right bro stay
healthy drink out of water oh hey he hey
hey what's up you going to the when is
the [__] next are you going to the
allar game in San
Diego no man they [__] uh their
tickets were [__] too much for that
[__] man like [__] how about those 8
seats outside game how about the 8 seats
outside where you can watch it no they
don't got that [__] they don't got that
[__] for this [__] bull that's what
I'm saying about the home and and they
[__] they're doing homeless sweeps
trying to get rid of all these
[__] before the [__] allar
game it's a big old Scandal right now D
put they even put some [__] like
where they used to sleep and [__] they
put like cemented in rocks and [__] it's
all Jagged and [__] and they can't
[__] lay down there no more come for
an expose video do they're doing the
same thing in Brazil bro they have cops
all over the area for the world Olympics
right and um and they have so many cops
in that area that that they never seen
that many cops in the tourist area but
the favelas whatever right yeah those a
little leave alone and they're keeping
anybody who look like a like a loser
away from the beach yeah kick your ass
out of there do want those tourist
dollars F yeah that's what's going on
right here crazy [__] yeah that sucks
bro so you got to sell your bootle
somewhere else huh yeah move it along
crazy
dog all right big dog thanks big frog
big frog he was our guest on the podcast
what's up for two guests called citric
and frog up [__] yeah hell yeah man
thank
you we got two guests hell yeah that's
[__] cool dog citric [__]
surprised me I was like hell yeah yeah
bro I'm a sick and tired man of cuz oh
God sick and tired being sick and
tired what's up
fool what's up fool who's this where you
calling
from this is Jefferson from Anaheim
Hills Orange County Jefferson what's up
Jefferson how are you I'm okay I just
got off work I ran home just to hop on
YouTube and call [__] yeah [__] yeah bro
where you work at I work in Anaheim like
uh next to Disneyland [__] Anaheim
Stadium or what at California Adventure
legol
Landing yeah
yeah yeah nearby yeah I work there
nearby hell yeah man hello you've been a
long time listening of our podcast no
actually I just I'm I'm a brand new fan
oh thank you bro [__] yeah dude check
out [__] Jefferson dog take you
Jefferson yeah you're growing audience
man the demand is there like you got
mexican-americans just like me you know
people want it people like you Felipe
thank you bro I like them bro hell yeah
you're a true a true patriot though
that's funny man when you said your name
was Jefferson I thought you were
Salvadorian H
Jefferson please call me
hefferson he likes big
chicks [__] cattle call over here
dog you can call me
he heer son he son I like that that's a
cool name though dude what's your last
name
Washington no Esquire
oh you're part of the Bush finally huh
we're [__] diamond in the rougher
over here you know hell yeah bro bro you
have the right bro stop what you're
doing right now bro stop [__] around
and and run for run run for politics bro
you got the perfect name to run for
Orange County bro your name is Jefferson
Esquire and your Latino bro hell yeah
you got the white votes already just for
that name yeah dude you and Ary Moreno
dog Kings of Anaheim Kings of Anaheim
bro you got the perfect name bro telling
you bro you have a perfect name to run
for office thank you I would vote for
you just on the name Esquire this s has
real estate I know this F needs a robe a
smoking jacket something jeon they need
a high school after
him or that bro or [__] that bro open up
a cleaning bro and callor The
Jeffersons yeah bro yeah so what kind of
law you practice
bro uh medical marijuana law of course
I'll go into that look at this [__]
Progressive over here I like you already
you know me you in Rodrigo bro you're G
run on a [__] riversite
ticket [__] Jefferson dog check this
fo out hell yeah man
JQ no j e hell yeah dude first Mexican
American ever met with that name bro but
I had a I have a cousin name his name is
yulis Grant no yulis something was she
cute no bro it's a guy a dark ass
fool that F over his
teeth like you's
juice thank you for calling bro much
oblig thank you so much for having me on
hell yeah keep listening subscribe to
the podcast and write a nice review oh
yeah let the legal Community know dog
hell yeah bro thank you yeah man bye you
guys 2020 ticket hell yeah keep shining
dog yeah
what's up
fool what's up F where you from man
where you calling from who this my name
my name is Jose Rodriguez bro I'm from
obiso
California over here by San Jose
California San Louis
Obispo no Al viso bro
viso Al viso Al viso Oh I thought you
said viso
horny Aliso I heard of Alviso yeah
Alviso is right by that exit that say ZZ
z z over here over here by Levi Stadium
bro the the 49er stadium by Channel a
all right bro you Morgan
Hill yeah somewh over there bro what's
up hey fipe yes bro I saw that [__] I
saw that Snapchat bro you look like
[__] s my yesterday
bro I know bro I'm telling you man I I
um I posted a photo of myself a long
time ago throwback to 20 2006 six and um
I I didn't have a beard and everybody
was
clowning a lot of people were clowning
funny ass [__] there somebody said bro
you look like [__] some high fat
sister my lady my lady thought I was
following whole bunch of girls and [__]
[__] is that what the [__] the
[__] F trip yeah bro I did a I did a a
Snapchat and I put the the the the I
don't know what it called the the snap
the little what the filter the filter of
a chick of um it makes you look with
blue eyes and lipstick and started doing
a little dance I do look like s bro I
didn't see that one do it's a good one
bro that's just funny it gets you
hard hard times I'm over here I'm over
here at work [__] I saw the the post
on Instagram so give these FS a call
[__] yeah dude say what's up bro
what's listen to it every Friday [__]
one one episode me like one day bro I I
commute a lot for work and I get stuck
in traffic I'll listen to that
[__] in one day thank you bro
hit that refresh button hell yeah bro
also listen to the
castle what I'll be there bro recording
my new
special hell yeah [__] give me first
on tickets bro let me buy mine first
well try
bro I don't know ifo what's up thank for
the follow on the Snapchat bro oh it's
all good dude [__] you're [__]
welcome dude thank you very much for
following and listening to all the
podcasts dude on the real thank you bro
to cool to follow back he well I'll
follow you back what's your name on
Snapchat I think it's a Jr
52 Jr 552 I got
You2 yeah send me a message and I follow
you way hell yeah yeah yeah for sure
thanks for picking up bro hell yeah bro
the squeaky whe gets oil hell
yeah what's up fool who is this thank
you for
calling hell yeah bro for get him back
bro what happened if anybody cuz there's
people man who make a lot of false
reports just because they have a a
grievance with somebody yeah that's
[__] criminal fool that's criminal
bro or or you know your your lady is
your ex-girlfriend is drunk and you give
her a [__] text in the middle while
she's driving and you cuz you know she's
going to look and she gets in a car
accident no dude those are both good
ideas and points and you know what
that's a [__] a aggressive ass
legislators out there in this [__]
State Should [__] look into it or the
Stupid 911 lady should say did you see
the gun [__] and but and you know what
dude they're supposed to be common cool
and sometimes they forget too dog so
what the [__] you know what mean you got
to be on point what's up fool what's
happening who we got hey hey this is a
JM right here calling out of Chino
California what's up Jerm what the [__]
com all the taking my call guys you're
welcome hell yeah bro you've been you've
been listening to our podcast in the
beginning oh you know it man you know
man all the time that's all I do man be
just chilling just listening to the
podcast smoking up hell yeah man germ I
know him from SoundCloud I I could tell
you how his little profile looks it's
blue with some kind of redish stuff and
glasses maybe I don't know man I don't
I'm not wearing my glasses when I see it
no it's it's me with my little bulk cup
man throwing up my metal horn yeah and
it's blue right that's me man hell yeah
bro that's me hey man just a quick
question man cuz I know you guys got you
know you guys are out of time um what's
up what's up with you guys are um you
guys play I I know you guys mentioned B
you guys performing BL and stuff days
ago though yeah we perform in BL long
time ago bro we used to perform at the
haunted
hotel oh [__] the hotel the hotel over
there yeah the hotel used to have a
little bar and we used to perform right
there in broy I think oh oh [__] man
yeah man because I used I used to stay
out there for a year man and I know
there's not much out there man but hell
no that's what's up man hell yeah other
left is Rats from the Sugar
Factory and one more thing man quick I
found your DVD with with you and Joey C
Diaz man what I'm talking about BR thank
you bro that CD has been sold everywhere
bro even in that CD used to be sold in a
Navy submarine for five bucks oh [__] I
found that [__] dog hey that's what sub
man but but hey man just thank you guys
for taking my call man and Rodrigo hey
I'm I'm digging the yeah man podcast and
and and Castro podcast is sound dope too
man but [__] yeah dog hell yeah yeah hey
man thank you guys for taking my call
man keep it T man for sure thank you
very much for listening spreading the
word dog yeah yeah you guys keep it
watching [__] yeah keep shining
dog the I always leave a message bro
germ German that's funny dude he's been
listening to day one hell what's up man
how's J bro you got lot still got a lot
of heat people still call dude I'm
[__] I'mma tell you man I don't
know what's going on man dude you guys
are [__] popular man people are still
[__] hit me up but you only other
thing sucks man they [__] want to
talk man you need a [__] ride or what
man that F's over there all dipping and
[__] being all popular right now fo
what's up
fool what's up man who's calling what's
up
turn down your little radio or whatever
turn down your computer
homie what's happening what's up guys
what's your name where you calling from
it's Rory from a d Rory Hill baby what's
happening dog what's happening man how's
it going man good how's the plant
business chilling how's the farm
looking oh it's looking real good man
can't wait for you guys to come out here
I'm going to put somebody on the phone
for yeah yeah H she don't want to jump
on the phone she's being shy all right
your little
daughter no Rebecca Rebecca what's up
F no Farm looking good man how's it
going guys getting ready to record that
special or what yeah we're going to
record that special on August 27 at the
San Jose Improv two shows my wife is
going to be there hanging out we're
going to have a good show and um also
man we're going to after we record the
album we're going to make a 100 Vino
albums that we're going to sell oh oh no
[__] yeah so so people so people could
frame them and put them in their house
and I'm G sign it yeah for sure man
that's awesome man sh I need to get you
to sign that poster yeah that little uh
that little 100 episode poster the ice
house yeah [__] yeah dude and we're
going to come we're coming to um parlor
bar in
Seattle yep y we'll be there we'll be
there bring a lot of people through man
for sure uh I don't know how much free
time you guys are going to have but um
so I'll take you guys out go do
something yeah November 3rd to the
5th oh [__] yeah how was your fourth of
July oh it was good man lit off a lot of
fireworks a lot of fire like those ones
you were talking about those mortars
yeah and we go to the the reses over
here the the the reservation that's
where they sell all those over here you
can't buy them like normally those the
on that you can hold and are those the
ones you hold and shoot in the
air well no they have a tube it's like
you actually they like uh has like a
three-inch tube and you drop that mortar
down inside there and it sh it's like
the ones you see at like Disneyland or
something like that smaller Native
Americans know how to build them huh oh
dud yeah well it comes from China
actually but what do they cost for a
mortar what do they cost for a mortar
like uh there's about pack of 24 on u a
pack of 24 for like H 60 bucks 75 bucks
not bad I I I get a little crazy Rebecca
gets mad at me dude I'm like a little
kid at Christmas
bro I spent too much money on that [__]
man yeah but it's a lot of fun little
cakes that have you know like 10 mortars
and it's light one fuse and it shoots
off all the mortars
and fing mortars
I yeah it's all about the Mor man tell
about the mortar Calibur is the name of
fuing morer over
here oh [__] what's up fol where you at
right now have a good I'm actually at
the house [__] man taking a break I was
actually a little sick so like [__] man
get a chance to call these guys [__]
yeah dude hell yeah you have a good
vacation rodo or what it wasn't really a
vacation but it was cool man [__] had
fun man nice to see [__] the people I
haven't seen in a long time good good is
that is that your Ruka on that picture
your Instagram picture which
one I don't know man no there's no no I
don't have a I don't have a picture of
yet okay up there no no he he don't show
no picture of his lady he's like
fluffy not official yet when it happens
we'll do it he like fluffy man he talk
he don't show none of his family members
just just
Volkswagen and
birds no we'll put him up though his
family the mystery those
my nieces dude this fool oh cool
cool history is no miss my L is only in
my
ACT not on Instagram I got a hide her
I'm not not me though fluffy they're
going to take her yeah they might take
her nobody wants her R me from the fame
hell yeah it's all good it's all love
good man GL I got talk to you guys man
I'm glad we talked again here in a
couple months [__] yeah dog always nice
seeing you dude you and your lady you
guys are [__] awesome y take care
guys see you peace out dog if you can't
laugh at what I just said you have no
sense of humor oh hell no F what's up
with everybody interprets like their
attacks or something everybody it's an
attack now it's an attack you can't bag
on me whatever happened to laughing at
somebody getting bagged on F yeah
whatever happened to
be I know people talk [__] about me it
better be
funny but dude as long as it's [__]
funny that's all that matters
dog fat sister that's what I'm saying I
don't give a [__] dude back on me all
you want just make sure [__]
laugh i' rather be her fat ass sister
than her gay ass brother making that
overpriced
Furniture yeah s brother sells Furniture
that's his little thing yeah I can't
wait till I become more popular and
let's see what kind of brother breaks
off with some [__] well don't you
have an artist in the family
F painting your living room is not an
artist
yeah got a photographer I had a cousin I
had a brother making wack cupcakes bro
that's what it was cupcakes dick [__]
Mak selling cupcakes bro to save up
money to go to Medical to go to nursing
school and then quit nursing school how
about give him that money
back what's up
fool
hello what up F what's up who's this
dog Chris from uh New
Mexico there you go what's up Chris from
New Mexico I think I saw your post on
Facebook
earlier um you know what it's a pretty
common name I don't I don't think that
was me all right sorry man because the
guy said um hey tacos in New
Mexico oh no man you know what I I
didn't really take too much care of my
teeth and one time I broke a [__]
tooth and I don't [__] with tacos no
more I'm all paranoid what are you rock
fuckos some hard ass
flout I I guess I get I guess I had some
[__] weak ass teeth you know that's
ain't the only thing that [__] up
[__] Taco
whistle I'm go here [__] drinking
soda out of a baby bottle dog
[__] took a bite off the
coke godamn you eat those Taco
sideways God damn but sometimes dog if
you don't know how if sometimes like I
remember like biting my tongue a lot
yeah I I always bite the side of my
mouth I just get pissed on Fu I used to
I used to bite the side of my mouth but
then fluffy he took he um he took me to
a dentist and I had all my four wisdom
tools removed is that what it was dude I
always bite the when I eat fast I bite
the S of this side dude like a [__]
animal dog only when you eat fast huh
yeah fool I bite my tongue when I'm
eating really fast like I'm like I'm
eating a taco and I'm dipping in
something yeah dude like I have the rule
as soon as I bite the side I stop eating
then dude so what you read now bro
burritos burrito
bowls Taco salads that taco soup no no
tortilla
soup so what's up man how's that what
part of New Mexico Albuquerque or Santa
Fe yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty close to
Albuquerque like kind like on the
outskirts so you guys do I just wanted
to I just you know I just want to show
y'all some love I listen to a lot of
podcasts man you know I listen to a lot
I started with Joe Rogan and all them
[__] really really I I can't I can't
really listen to them too much you know
blah blah blah blah blah they get too
much into the science and I'm not really
into MMA but I listen to you and Uncle
Joey that's what I'm [__] talking
about Rodrigo of course absolutely thank
you you know any anytime I having like a
bad day at work or some [__] you want to
stringle the boss hey just put on what's
up for you want to stringle the
boss hell yeah bro listen to the listen
to the podcast I feel you dog get away
that one that one fool had me dying when
he was talking about uh cat say oh you
just want to go on stage and kill huh
[__] got punched in the
gut Dem milit Dem milit yeah
[__] Cat Williams punched that
girl in the gut yeah [__] that for going
over that should be a message to
everybody bro [__] dude I don't even
understand how [__] go over on
a guest spot or like I remember the
manager saying a long time they always
do the famous line all right guys I got
to go my time is up like they're going
to say please don't go stay [__] out of
here
dog [__] dude the opener what yeah
[__] we gotta get you some shoes
with some helies on so [__] with the
remote control dog [__] hits 459 get the
[__]
off I know man should be a
trapo that's what I'm saying fool [__]
that dude cuz you know in the old days
bro if the king and that that Jester was
performing for for the king and he like
started going over he got killed oh dude
was it Off With His Head bro remember
imagine bro there was two gestur or
three gestur and then I was going up
before those guys I would have did the
material this fo dog what happened bro
man I killed it what happened to the
other G they killed too they got killed
they
died God damn F hell yeah man thank you
very much for listening hey bro what do
you is it true that people from new
mexic New Mexico they put that green
chili on
everything uh you know what there is
there is some people that that do that
um I know like like my dad every now and
then you know if he gets a little hungry
he'll pull out the chili and just eat it
with like some chips or some [__] or
just you know throw it in real quick God
a
Savage but uh the thing is down here red
or green red or green and me personally
I like green I like the green chili me
too man I like green chili and chiladas
hell yeah dog hell yeah I'm hungry now
those are bomb dude I have those till
2003 or something well thanks for
calling
bro appreciate I don't want to hold up a
question go ahead sorry you have a
question oh no no I just I better get
off and let let everybody else get on I
have a question bro uh do they do they
film better car saw in New in New
Mexico yeah oh you know what I got a
funny ass story about that I that they
do go for it do uh but whenever they uh
had just finished Breaking Bad We went
to go watch WWE my dad like hey man you
want to go see where uh what's his name
uh Walter's house is at I was like yeah
dude those people were get the [__] off
our lawn it's just a show get the [__]
out of here do I'm like what the like
dude they were tripping now at at Jess's
house it's all good yeah there's a
stabbing there you know it's it's next
to a crazy Park which is crazy but uh
yeah Walter's house you got to you know
those people are a little nuts I don't
know how they are now this is like
couple years ago oh do a Snapchat dog
you should have [__] threw a pizza on
the roof and ran
bro I mean they're stupid they could pay
you know go ahead and chill do whatever
you want pay five bucks you know they
could be making money on the side yeah
little tour [__] kicking people
out I know man walking in their lawn and
[__] oh pissed off man crazy that's a
good story hell yeah thank you thank you
for sharing there dog appreciate it
thank you apprciate it right here with
Albuquerque's finest you know hell
yeah
B everywhere and remember when we were
in Albuquerque that one time they said
that the [__] cops be shooting a lot
of fools in albuqu cops and New Mexico
shoot a lot of people man but they don't
CH advise it because Brown lives don't
matter I'm just kidding everybody
matters thank you bro all right thank
you hell yeah keep shining dog hell
yeah what's up fool thank you for
calling what what's
up what's happening who is
this he Tony what's happening Tony where
you calling
from from Palmdale God damn what's up
Palmdale in the house Palmdale in the
house been out here for a year oh where
you from
originally well I grew up in the
noodles in the
noodles in the noodles you know what the
noodles are
no Avenue 43 oh yeah oh [__] right here
in okay Avenue 43 hell yeah I've been in
Monella for about 10 years before coming
up here and how do you like it over
there it's a house so it's great hell
yeah man long as you have air
conditioning everything's going to be
all
right no no more apartment hell no man
you're a homeowner in Palmdale that's
right barbecuing and
hotness everything it's I wanted to tell
you I saw you on 12 13 14 at
portal but I it was your wedding day but
I didn't know it was your wedding day
and I didn't know that you were
approachable oh yeah I think that's when
you guys were getting all those snacks
in the morning went to go some get some
get some drinks or waiting for the big
day hell yeah at Portos yes we were
there with George Clooney yeah we were
there in the morning the day of the
wedding and we were getting a bunch of
snacks me Rodrigo Birman and
Chris yep me and my husband saw you I'm
like that's him that's him 12 13 14 hell
yeah you should have said hello I
thought I didn't think that you were
gonna be friendly so I I backed down I
back down stand your ground Me gangster
hell
yeah what wow man so how long you been
You' been do you do um you and your
husband listen to the
podcast uh I do because he's working all
day but I I tell him everything that
goes on all right thank you yeah
actually my kids are the ones I used to
watch you on YouTube and then that's how
I got um turned on you guys and I thank
you actually when we were at portals I
called my son I'm like what's the name
of the guy that you're watching on
YouTube he's here at
portal but that was it how how old is
your
son uh now he's 17 so this was maybe
about two years ago he what's his name
Watching You on YouTube his name is
James James what's up fool thank you for
turning your mom on to to me thank you
very much and hopefully when you turn 18
you come come see me yeah man right
right
right and then Lisa she's right here to
keep this to keep the singing up on the
inada of cassero in the beginning sounds
good thank you we're gonna do a new
podcast this week tonight all right I'm
all up to date thank you and Rodrigo I
think he only has one up he's slipping I
have there six up now oh I'm slipping
then my bad they're on Soundcloud
Stitcher and uh iTunes so yeah hell yeah
yeah and on Soundcloud I don't know how
to leave a review but if I did I would
put it right on okay just hit the little
icon but you'll figure it out yeah I'll
figure it out thank you thank you very
much Al righty
alrighty all right guys take care all
right like right there in Palmdale wrap
it up yeah man what's up fool want more
to call it or wrap it up one more color
one more color what's up homie what's
your name hey what what's up for it's
Mar
sa what's happening how you happening I
what what's up I didn't recognize I
thought was a little girl calling no
it's it's me I had to call in I heard
citri call in I made sure to have him
call so just wanted to say what's up
what's up fol how everything going
everything's good uh we were looking
forward to seeing you out in humph but I
guess uh the date changed yeah the the
he got changed to October
21st oh okay cool we'll be down there
we're we're trying to get down there so
cool man for sure how's everything with
you man you auditioning or what's up
working on any movies uh yeah trying to
do some little side work but I still got
my 9 to-5 so still doing it um shout out
to the first uh call-in show I had um
some followers follow me because they
had heard me on here so that's dope hell
yeah Maris Montes people Instagram she's
back the haters are gone I'm back the
haters are gone I'm back I'm doing my
thing um shout out to
5150 um if uh anybody's out there check
us out um on the IG on our website um
we're gonna be doing a lot of events
coming up so trick is really busy with
the whole 5150 plus the Lopez Land on TV
hell yeah um season two coming soon and
uh we got a dope crew and big things are
coming so shout out to you too Rodrigo
for the Y Man uh podcast so oh thank you
very much thank you so much thank you
for yeah we try to support him we try to
uh share it as much as we can I mean
it's dope we're we're big fans of both
the webs up fo and the enchilada
casserole too than big old fan of that
too so thank you right on hell yeah man
stay up stay up stay yeah just wanted to
say what's up and keep it keep
everything good and uh good luck to um
all your guys success also shout out to
5150 clothing bro hell yeah man doing
big things bro they're about to videos
and want to follow us um it's a on IG
it's a 5150 brand you heard people and
then myself is um the one and only Mar
sa on IG the one and
only what was that I said the one and
only the one and only the only one oh
yeah yeah but anyways just thought I
would call in real quick you know big
fan thank you Montes keep shining long
time listener yeah from the beginning
long time from the beginning
bro y yep yeah we took a photo I took a
photo at the ice house one time years
ago huh years ago yeah what's up
fo all right man that was our our Colin
show which we're going to do once a
months F Rodrigo Tes you have dates um
no um just the the dates we have there
just [__] uh doing spots in town and
um that's it man what I got right now
and your podcast on Soundcloud on
Soundcloud Stitcher and iTunes also man
what's up full podcast listen to us
subscribe to us write a review and
follow us and Au things comedy check out
all the all things
comedy um podcast support the the shows
the live show they have at the nerd
mount with Bill Burr and M magical John
he I don't know I'm just making I'm read
I'm reading out a [__] poster right
now what's up fo thank you very much I
we love you I personally want to say
that um without you guys would just be a
podcast with no listeners but you guys
listen to all three podcast thank you
for supporting us and listening to us
and look out for a live what up F
podcast comedy show in the near future
hell yeah dude and U we got a couple of
more shout outs here thank you very much
for always reviewing it on iTunes and
getting it on the charts dude and
without you we would just be you know
chilling we just be reviewing movies by
ourselves shout out to Eric Sate I
couldn't get in to call oh my God shout
out to Eric sarate he couldn't get in to
call but you got a shout out bro and um
shout out to everybody who wanted a
shout out hell yeah next time send a
pigeon hell yeah man send something
man thank you hell yeah thank you very
much guys
late let's cool